[Music]
who here saw the Avengers did you see
crazy this is interesting the Avengers
had the biggest opening in movie history
beating the record held by Harry Potter
yeah that's true that's true
as a result filming has begun on the new
Harry Potter movie Harry Potter sits in
a theater watching The Avengers I
[Applause]
wouldn't just use the wand to like I
know Hey Vice President Joe Biden said
something interesting in a new interview
Vice President Joe Biden said the sitcom
Will & Grace made America more
comfortable with gay people yeah yeah
Biden Biden also said the sitcom
character echo made America more
comfortable with President Obama
that's the extent of my all right
speaking of President Obama President
Obama has officially kicked off his
campaign President Obama says his
campaign for a second term is still
about hope and change yeah the the
president's exact words were I hope I
won't have to change my address
slightly less inspiring jay-z's in the
news jay-z said that his new daughter
Blue Ivy will be the worst most spoiled
kid ever
yeah when asked for comment Kanye West's
father said bring it
[Applause]
[ __ ]
jeopardy host Alex Trebek may be
retiring soon yeah yeah people suspected
Trebek had become too old for the job
when he went around asking what is my
name the joke works but I care all right
last time I take you to lunch France has
a new president who lives with a woman
that he is not married to their
relationship is described as French I
couldn't believe this a new report says
that IKEA IKEA may have used political
prisoners to make some of their
furniture yes yes
yeah which probably explains why the
instructions for the new IKEA futon say
sure I'm being tortured but at least I
don't have to put together this futon
[Music]
in Colorado a first-grade boy was
charged with sexual harassment after he
sang the words to a rap song in the boys
defense he does like big butts and he
cannot lie
I couldn't lace the Octomom just filmed
her first porn movie in fact it had the
only opening bigger than the Avengers
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay now I'm drifting what am i doing
what's the point you we should just do a
kayak show or something
yeah flood the studio and you can do the
whole thing on a gun it's not a kayak
that's a canoe I don't do this whatever
do I do I do this we don't you don't
need a double paddle for a kayak do you
why did I take you to lunch the purpose
of the lunch would support me in the
model I know no such things well that's
what happened
that doesn't match the one who said
kayak and you could have just gone with
it you'd already be telling them who's
on
I can't believe we're letting America
see our spare 39
I said kayak and you couldn't just let
it go